florida set a state record for covet
hospitalizations for the third straight
day yesterday more than
11 500 patients florida and texas
together
have about one-third of all the new
covid cases in america
president biden criticized their
governors who have blocked
new covet regulations i say to these
governors please
help but you aren't going to help at
least get out of the way
the people are trying to do the right
thing
use your power to save lives
joining us now is dr ashish he is dean
of brown university school of public
health
dr good morning we always tell people
listen to the doctors if you were
confused so what do you say to the
governors
of florida and texas good morning david
thanks for having me here what i say to
them
is that these are very very difficult
times right now and i would not see
these things as regulations as much as
public health measures
to save lives and there's a series of
things we can do
because we've learned a lot about this
virus to get through the delta surge and
get to the other end
and have a lot more people alive and
safe if we make these public health
measures if we put them into place
new york city they're going to require
people to be vaccinated before they go
indoors
do you believe at this point given the
available data that you've looked at
do you think right now mandates are our
most effective way out of this pandemic
you know david i do and i don't know
that we need to have
a lot of government mandates though i
actually i do believe what new york city
do is doing is
is really reasonable obviously this is a
choice issue for some people they don't
want to be vaccinated i understand that
but if you want to participate in in a
restaurant you want to make keep
restaurants safe if you want to go to a
hospital you want to go into
a university it makes a lot of sense for
those institutions to say
we want everybody vaccinated it makes it
creates a safe space for people so
i support mandates and i think that they
are going to help a lot of people get
off the fence and get vaccinated
booster shots a lot of people will ask
me when i'm out in the street
david do we need booster shots what do
the doctors say what do you think
yeah this is one where my views have
changed because the science has changed
we've seen a lot of new data coming out
in the last
month or so primarily from israel
elsewhere
that frail elders for instance who are
more than six months out from their
second shot
they may need a booster uh other people
amino compromise people need a booster i
don't know that everybody in america
needs a booster i think i haven't seen
any data that says that's
uh true but i think for some high-risk
people boosters make a lot of sense
louisiana is one of the hottest hot
spots right now but you know what as
vaccinations as the infections and
hospitalizations are rising
so too is the vaccination rate what do
you make of that a lot of people are
scared right now and that's driving them
to get vaccinated
yeah david that's been one of the
heartening things i have seen in the
recent days
is that a lot of people in these places
that have had low vaccinations
are stepping up are deciding that they
want to protect themselves they want to
protect their families
they're seeing what's happening in their
communities and getting vaccinated
of course i wish people had gotten
vaccinated earlier but at the at this
point
we've got to do everything we can to
protect people and that means getting
more and more people vaccinated
dr ashisha thank you for your time